[Music]  tonight I'm proud to announce our newest  addition to the team cocoa web presence  conan dot triple x this this is not a  joke this is not a joke this is a real  xxx domain website check it out it's  it's up it's on yeah this is real right  now it only has one video on it this is  what we call in the business a soft  launch all right  now here's a sneak preview of the first  conan dot triple x-- video it's called  one guy two bulls what's your name  andy and how old are you Andy 45 and do  you know why you're here  I mean I have a pretty good idea let's  do you super have you ever had two soups  at once I don't know which one I like  better I'm glad I wore my glasses that  I'm Gary of my eye  [Applause]  again this is a real site so go check  out the rest of Andy's one guy two bowls  at conan dot XXX  [Applause]  we're gonna get more and more